first thing I'd like to do is thank all
our sponsors that helped us put together
my input and my upper teeth that I'm on
the streets or the less South Dakota
wheat commission Farm Credit Services of
America wheat growers Mustang seat
Montana first agencies next level egg
LLC billboards needs lacrosse needs the
capacity add Rodney Plus farmers
Alliance missile first coat of National
Bank CB operations of the experiment
stopped replying content that's
unlimited for our County Conservation is
B Davidson County Conservation is we had
to Comicon survey statistics output on
sale Association SDSU extension USD and
NRCS and pioneer hi-bred the DuPont so
let's give them all over welcome
anyway you guys without any more is
playing back from the collection
research this is just how we move wire
you can see there's lire on that
irrigator these are lateral moves that
move straight we also have pivot to go
go around but we just have the wire
running through there in those buckets
there's a rope hanging down with a fence
post on it and and those buckets give a
just enough weight that it doesn't the
fence doesn't blow and and and stuff
like that so that works pretty good you
do like Dan does you get Cody to do it
and Casey you know but these are these
are bar jay-z Catalan and once we
started moving if they could hear the
irrigator you can see them my daughter
took that with her cell phone so it was
into the Sun you can't see it so good
but terrible place to work it's kind of
like here when you look out the window
but as soon as they heard that motor
those irrigation pivot motors run and
they're just a word they're not very
loud but they could hear them and they
just come they'd come at a dead run and
so we were actually moving out of corn
stalks into swath grazing and I just
said move that Cheviot and those in the
process and then I've got the next
saddle show they're moving from this
field into the corn stalks so we had a
time what we did is we swath grazed
between I'll show you all the quality
and stuff we swath grades between this
oats and pea cover crop that was growing
behind winter wheat and then corn stalks
and until we balanced a diet I think hen
was talking about is exactly right
exactly the thing we do with the thing
we do with a farm ground in terms of
trying to build organic matter in feed
them soil microorganisms actly the same
thing and everybody wants to do turnip
and radishes and clover and whatever
well that's not enough carbon you have
too much nitrogen you just burn it up
and and you've got to have the balanced
diet now here the cows are moving we
move this lateral move down here they're
moving you'll notice if you look closely
they they mostly have collars on and
they have little fitbit's on their feet
and and what those collars do is tell
you how much their head is moving up and
down and eating and then the Fitbit
tells you how many steps and to be real
honest with you I haven't analyzed all
that that data yet because they're just
a mountain of data that we've got to
take care of this big draw here there's
some tall grass prairie there and
there's big draw there with tall grass
prairie that's our our area they could
get into when it got cold and crappy and
that's something you got to think about
it wind breaks and stuff until we had
that Christmas blizzard that's what
happened I move the pivot again you
watch them coming from back over here at
a dead run down to this pivot so they
they really like to swaths ot stuff
because that was the candy but you also
have to it's like we were joking here
everybody's coming over and getting
roles right it's a bit too much
carbohydrate so and and and those of you
that had that had hamburgers you got a
chance because you had your protein
right but I'm not sure you might have to
eat another steak before you leave here
if you do them any more so the Cole X
research farm is owned by farmers and
and actually the idea for the cold lake
started at the old steak house down over
the hill one night after field day in
the in the 80s and some guys said well
we want to we should have a research
farm and I just said you don't want the
government to own it
you want to own it yourself because the
government owns it you can never tell
what's going to happen and you got to
have the government involved and that's
me to a certain extent working for SDSU
but we we have to have the farmers own
dan is actually our president now so our
board of directors is important to us
I'm just going to be real brief today
the climate will change but it will
still be a continental climate will
still have cold winters here relatively
cold winters cold and dry normally
winters will have hot and dry summers
that's not going to change now it's
going to change a bit but we're still
going to be a continental climate not
going to turn into a California or a
Florida a bigger issue though and at
least in your Mike lifetimes in the next
600 years or something which is beyond
our lifetime degradation the ecosystem
will have more potential impact and I
just wrote one of those articles for
farm journal it at one time we had the
Cronin's involved in and now I've got a
guy from Nebraska than working with but
I talked about that and especially as
you sit along the Missouri River here
and one of the things I think about is
all the people used to travel up and
down this river and think of what they
found when they came through here and
how is it different now from when it was
when they came and in you know four or
five hundred years or when Lewis and
Clark came through and and it wasn't
like what the revenant shows by the way
that was supposed to be here but we
don't have the big force of stuff we
didn't have that much climate change in
the last 200 years but but anyway but
what we've done is we took the land
around Gettysburg and we took the
organic matter down to half of what it
was when we came here and so it didn't
hold as much water and it wasn't as
resilient as it should have been and so
when I taught school here in 1975
through 78 which some of you didn't know
but a lot of you did she was a student
not one of mine but she was a student
she's like a freshman
when I left but we had dirt blown over
the road all time and we could only do
wheat and Sommerfeld and look at what's
different now and and it's because we
started to restore that soil to where it
should be and it holds more organic
matter than it did in 1976 and not as
much as it did in 1776 okay so this is
the thing we need to look at and that's
the thing we talked about in cattle I
think integration plays a role in that
ecosystems harvest sunlight energy and
drive all other process removing the
products from the ecosystem reduces the
energy available when the worst things
you can do is make hay on a piece of
ground and hold the hay off and not
bring anything back it's one of the
worst things you can do to an ecosystem
and so our North unit if you're familiar
with our farm we've got a half section a
big half section plus of 45 miles north
and it's been healing for a guy from the
1930s on incredibly degraded ecosystem
and we bought it in 2000 and now we've
got it somewhat restored to lease it's
way better than what it was when we took
over it's better than the neighbours
pasture that's over grazed right before
it probably wasn't nutrients or all the
nutrients available or plant use or
environmental services or behave they'd
been leached eroded or transported from
the landscape if you've got saline seats
and those kind of things it's because
your nutrients are leaving where they
belong and going someplace else
that's fertilizer and those saline seeps
and we're going to eventually have to
put perennials systems back in there to
suck up those nutrients and big them
back to the top and then graze them and
put them back into place that's what
happened in the native Prairie
cover crops will help us balance our
water cycle a little better but they
won't totally do it on their own
ecosystems that leak nutrients turn into
desert
that's what's happened in North Africa
and all these places think about Israel
the land of milk and honey
climate hasn't changed that much in the
intervening years what happened is they
degraded the ecosystem and you can read
a thing that that a guy by the name of
Loudermilk wrote in the 1930s it's just
phenomenal what he found when he went to
Israel and looked what the soils are and
what they should have been we're doing
the same thing 120 car train of soybeans
contains 400,000 pounds of phosphorous
think of how many unit trains go out of
cell V and all these little circle
tracks here and there and across the
United States and they're all going
someplace like China they're not going
to send that phosphorus back to us so
we're mining when we're doing that we're
mining we're not farming remaining we're
taking the nutrients out send them
across the road February 20th last
Saturday or last something like that it
costs two dollars and 25 cents a bushel
to shift corn bushel corn to the west
coast from Aberdeen an elevator managed
from Aberdeen talking to me on the phone
and he says it costs me two dollars and
25 cents a bushel to ship my corn to the
west coast does that make any damn sense
hey making sense to me I mean why the
hell are we doing it and then they're
going to feed animals over there with it
with our and then their phosphorus is
there so we're spending that kind of
money and then we're loops sending the
phosphorus with it and Coltrane contains
7,200 tons of coal but when you're
digging up coal you're admitting to be a
miner that's what you do we take an oil
out your miner you know you're going to
take it it's just going to be gone but
when we started farming our gained
organic matter went out it was the same
thing
we took their gaining matter out gas it
off right and it would take at least one
coal train per half section in the top
just for the top six inches
a rain I mean top six inches of soil to
take all the organic matter that we lost
it's out of the top six inches one
Coltrain for a half section so if we're
going to restore to 2% in that top six
inches we're going to if we're going to
do that down to two or three foot just
think how many train loads of coal we'd
have to bring back in it's amazing
so we're partially using cover crops
through large extent to catch carbon in
the air and put it in the soil one of
the things I talk a lot and Danny's
heard me do this but when you ship out
oil we're working with cold pressing
sunflowers in in in soybeans and flax
and whatever and we cold press it we get
the oil out of it we got good meal I
gave Don a bucket of soybean meal that
we we use for a protein supplement the
stuff that's left when we press the oil
out and and and now when we ship the oil
out all we've shipped out is carbon
dioxide and water
there's no minerals in there and mother
nature brings your back water she brings
you back carbon dioxide in the air and
if we do it right she brings your back
nitrogen in the air right we're not
transporting anything now if we use
those things here and keep all the
minerals here then we cut down this big
transportation thing in six hundred
years or 200 years or a hundred years
it's transportation thing just going to
get a bigger and bigger a bigger problem
right so there's our catching the
nitrogen we call his catch and release
nutrients you know what I stole that
from a guy in North Dakota but I got I
got another one from Jake Jake Fuhrer
the other day I got everything put it in
but he said a light bulb did not result
from somebody incrementally trying to
make candles better we're great we got
it we got to start thinking different so
to just keep trying to do what we're
doing to do a little bit better we'll
still have a damn candle so 1970 the
average wheat price was dollar 37 a
bushel average price of barrel oil is
three dollars and thirty nine cents
price of barrel oil today is just south
of 60 bucks and wheats about three and a
half or four think about that 80% 80% of
the total input cost and agriculture can
be traced directly to energy so
incrementally trying to do better and
better and still relying on all this
energy doesn't make any sense because
we're losing the oil is going up faster
120 years ago we essentially were zero
don brought his dad down John he's 100
and 103 and he looked at the cows you
remember what he said he said if they're
eating the sloth he says well they're
bailing they're hauling the bales and
they're hauling the manor back out right
oh yeah that's it I thought that was
pretty good uh-oh you got the essence of
the whole thing right there 120 years
ago that was zero 120 years from now
we're going to have to be zero again
right now today we're talking about
grazing y-l and savouries been mentioned
a few times and he talked about brittle
or environment through dry climates
right well he's saying it's a hoof
action I think it's also in dry climate
soil biology slows or stops during
periods of low moisture the rumen of
grazing animals remains moist during
button continuing those biological
processes the process in the soil are
almost exactly the same as a process in
the rumen there's almost no different
and somebody said and I thought it was
Darwin but I can't find the
the quote that somebody called the soil
the rumen of the earth if you know who
that was Cody would that was you that
did this so after you left the school
mines right okay but but that's the idea
behind grazing animals being important
in dry climates are relatively more
important to dry climates in cold
climates the same thing soil biology
slows during times of low soil moisture
or low soil temperatures the room and
the grazing animals are always warm they
keep it going during the winter that's
the role we're cycling it we're not
getting rid of the organic matter
recycling it okay so here some of our
cover crops that would be our oats and
pea thing we swap it the slots have to
be relatively big so they don't get
covered up with snow the Canadians are
not worried about snow depth you know
those cows that go out there and really
deep snow if they can see it and they
will drive on if it gets to be hard snow
they'll just I have a tractor on it just
or a pickup and just to break the snow
but we had some pretty deep snow and it
didn't seem to bother the cows a bit
that's what it looks like in the fall
you know nice and green in there it
stayed green like that until basically
we were done grazing til is all gone we
had a couple fields where we had oats
peas and rapeseed winter wheat stubble
is going to be seated to corn in 2017 in
this field in particular had seven
thousand seven hundred pounds of biomass
per acre 18.2% of protein and 121
relative feed value zero three which was
that pivot you saw a little bit less
biomass not a lot seventeen point four
protein 115 now since ken was here you
saw me goofing with the computer because
I went back and got some he he started
using something I didn't have on there
so he was using tdn so our t DN was 72%
on these oat p rapeseed things
protein 17.4 that ratio is 4 to 1 so
it's too hot if all we did is graze that
that's not that's too hot we're just
going to waste it right it's it's like
you guys eating nothing but steak you
need to have some carbohydrates to go
with it so we we were grazing these
swaths at the same time we were allowing
the college to have access to corn
stocks not corn but corn stocks after
after harvest and that's how we balance
the diet and so one of the things if
you're planning to do cover crops it'd
be good to plan to have some source of
corn stalks or perennial pastures or
something like that you could use for
your filler so to speak instead of and
that's what we did we could vary the
moves to make them go to the corn stalks
and get full instead of just just eat
the oats so this is the reason for
grazing and material association a
little quality corn stock aftermath in
at the end of the grazing period
mid-january when Don come and got the
cows they we had a few sloths left and
went and pulled a sample out of the out
of those last sloth 16.8 still 16.8
versus you know just still just 17
something TD and a sixty five point one
and still had a relative few value of 95
so we lost a little bit of a little bit
of quality but not very dang much in
that period so I'm fairly confident in
the East here now if I lived I grew up
in Platte which is just west of course
because so you know in that area a
little bit more fall rains and stuff it
might be a bit different but hitting in
this country I'm not afraid of that
thing at all so what we did here is a
rope coming down from the irrigators
that bucket there's two wires one here
and here and yeah we should have had a
third when it gets really iced up you
should have that ground in the middle
and we had a couple cows I give you the
numbers
that you'd move them back through the
fence and they turn around come right
back through the guys screw you I know
this thing isn't going to hurt me
because it's icy now here I'm moving I
said we should be moving perpendicular
this loss we just couldn't arrange it to
do that this year the way we had things
set up so we're moving like larry was
parallel parallel to the swass and it's
not ideal but we didn't we didn't have
we were done with this field before we
had snow so we moved about every day and
a half we gave them to sloths or sixty
feet and you can kind of see this we
these are where the moves before we
didn't have a back fence here we had
water on this road and then there's corn
stalks on the other side of the road but
then about every five or six days we
would throw back fencing or some side
fence so they couldn't get back and just
loaf around back over here but they
didn't spend a lot of time back there
they cleaned up pretty well and you can
see down through there the the wheat
stubble this is 120 bushel wheat stubble
underneath this is the court this is a
this is the stubble from the oats and
they left the stubble the ate the swath
they left the stubble there's and then
we had all the stuff from the crop that
we'd harvested lay down in there so
there's good armor there and you see
it's high quality stuff and we did fecal
sample and they haven't gotten those
back yet but we did fecal sample and
regular basis and we we thought that
worked pretty good last year when we did
study to tell us if we're getting a
little lower protein there it's coming
through corn stalks on wheat stubble
that will be seeded to soybeans we put
in oats German millet Brown Madrid
sorghum Sudan and somebody talked about
this not quite as much biomass because
it didn't grow into that late fall this
year you know that sportage sorted with
self quit relatively early proteins a
little lower for all T p-values pretty
good that's what it looked like where
the hay mill is just starting to head
out
oats is coming up through there
that's what looked like in the swath
this is actually from a year ago I took
these in there we had to the sloth
running this way and we're moving the
fence perpendicular to the sloth and
they would and we had a bit of snow a
year ago and they would just follow that
swath just fine
see and you can't you can't see where
that swath is but it's there but that
tells them there's a swath there as soon
as you move that wire they'll just come
to those spots and there's like twelve
or fifteen of them and the way they go
we like bigger buckets better than the
small buckets a five gallon buckets
worked better actually so there's so
these were barge AZ cattle mature cows
various genetics
you can ask Don about that late second
trimester and we had a few opens in
there 60-day grazing period initial
weight of 1392 pounds final weight of
fourteen forty nine forty seven pound
gain so I did that wrong fifty seven
pound gain typo title and you're looking
at no they meant game were net and there
was a few that didn't gain a couple of
them lost some weight and there's
something that did way better than the
others which is kind of interesting but
we did a sixty days forty seven acres of
oat P and six acres that millet stuff
and then seventy-five acres of corn
stock swap out P we we shot for a
grazing or what we have is a grazing
intensity of five eight a um per acre on
those cover crops of high-quality stuff
and then since we have more acres the
corn stocks now we're doing these at the
same time so the average is about a
tooth is really what you get out of that
if you if you do it and we just give a
mineral and salt at lib and you can't
possibly write this down in time but
but they're going to have they're going
to have a copy but all I did is you just
Google swath grazing Alberta and you'll
get this now the government of elet
Saskatchewan and Alberta in Manitoba
worked on swath grazing since I've been
married in we've been married 29 years
and we ran into this then and one of the
reasons they really did a lot of this
especially in the interim is is mad cow
disease because if you if you lived in
Canada and your cow calf died 15 years
ago an old cow killer cow was worth
seven cents American so you got to take
something out of your system in order to
be profitable or you got to get out of
the business and this is one way they
did it and and they did this a couple of
these large studies somebody showed
something from University of Brandon or
whatever it was actually a granada'
Brandon was one of the stations and they
took a 600 Cal herd and split it into
three herds at 201 Set stayed in the
feedlot all year one set feedlot in the
winter they went they went out into
perennial pastures in the summer the
other side of 200 just was in Fields
grazing annual crops in production field
the one that performed the bat they went
they went in and for five or six weeks
and captive they went into the buildings
but other than that they were out doing
their thing and and and the best herd
health the best performance the best
whatever was the ones that route
the new manager the AG research center
in Rapid City the Western campus of SDSU
so to speak the livestock people were
Ken works and the new person there we
were they were hiring they were they
were interviewing for that position I
was on the committee that came down to
last two and I
housed both of them the question do you
think they'll be feedlots in 40 years
you know but what a curveball right if
you're somebody applying for a job and
some guy asked you that question but one
of them answered the one that actually
got the job immediately said no and and
then the follow-up question is how do
you change the way you do AG research in
western South Dakota to get ready for
the vent reality of not having calves go
right to feed Lots now why don't white
why do I think there probably won't be
feed Lots in 40 years 60 years whatever
because you've got antibiotic resistance
you've got huge problems with energy to
take you know take do silage I don't
know what your site is cutting cost
Danny a lot I mean that's the way you
say that
and baling and hauling and whatever and
then you have tried to haul the
nutrients back out and we saw the data
today already that if fat cow peas and a
feedlot versus being out in the field
it's a huge difference in terms of
nitrogen so huge difference in terms of
phosphorus cycling so we really don't
have a choice
we need to get them back out in the
field I mean it's not one of those
things like we have a choice it's a one
of the thing that we're going to be
forced to do it eventually so we're
better off to do it when we start so I
that's a good place these are really
interesting videos in Raleigh leaves
Minh who isn't here but I hope to bring
him today but he's heading to Falls for
the rustling terminus sons in the
wrestling tournament and he didn't want
to get stuck not being there but he
wintered 400 head of cows and 370 acres
of corn failed corn this year he
wintered 400 acres of cows on 370 acres
of failed Corney at 370 acres of failed
corn north of blunt some gravely ground
got dry and he wintered his whole herd
there so what you know he was just one
move and I feel lying Helen she's put
your college in there and I told him
build fences and stuff he didn't
necessarily do that but he they're still
there
he says most money ever made growing
corn have it failed he got he got his
insurance payment right
fluffy he grades all he's God you
haven't said any hay or any silage all
year so and and and he got I sent him
this link and then I started getting
text last night he was watching his
videos and he then we always text and
commenting and whatever and I'm going
okay this picture was taken and just on
the outskirts of Lloydminster
Saskatchewan about 12 years ago
Lloydminster Saskatchewan is straight
straight east of Edmonton long ways
north right long ways north long way
north the border probably four or five
hours north of the border right on the
Alberta Saskatchewan border the border
of Alberta and Saskatchewan was right
through the middle of Lloydminster so
kinda like Pierre Fort Pierre only is
not a river there there's just a lie
just like a little sign they have been
doing this for a long time they grow
corn just to grapes okay now more goats
more cows more sheep why you say goats
number one meat eaten in the world is
goat just so you Cowboys don't get too
arrogant in Africa all the little girls
take care of the goats rate 100%
grass-fed ground beef this was produced
in Aberdeen South Dakota like coke coal
cows in Montana bring them to Aberdeen
feed them on cover crops and they're
grass-fed because they haven't had green
interesting content
four bucks a pound and the world's
supply of my noble Foster's will have
exhausted in less than 120 years and the
people that have the minor bowl
phosphors are not our friends probably
even more so now use of perennial
sequences of perennial cover crops will
probably be necessary to get our
nutrient cycling rate mother nature does
not do tillage unless it's a
catastrophic event and she does not
export nutrients okay all tillage tools
destroy soil structure all tillage tool
degree water and filtration all tillage
tools reduce organic matter and all
tillage tools increased wheat and in
central South Dakota we all know this
I'm heading to Missouri next week they
don't know this a really slow learners
in Missouri mother nature does not kick
oh that show me yes oh man she does max
here which species survive or die
right we don't have to do this to save
the planet plan we'll be fine without it
but we'll probably be without it unless
we do something different
bureaucracies like universities
governments and corporations are
operated by people with limited tenure
some with shorter tenure than others but
whatever
as a joke worked better last week they
have short term goals right they're just
thinking about three four years in
society landowners farmers you know
family farmers we need to have long term
research and that's what the code lakes
does farmers and ranchers harvest
sunlight carbon dioxide and water
produce products we can sell doesn't
make any difference some of this is
human food so we need to be aware of
nutritional issues off-site impact we
want to eat meat maybe we should
concentrate on growing meat instead of
corn and barley the goats feedlot and
feed animals you know doesn't making
sense
Peak Oil is when you're half done with
oil production in the world peak
phosphorus we're hit both peak oil and
peak phosphorus already
peak soil one half of soil is screwed up
we're probably past that you know nobody
nobody is panicked other than me take
the e out of e t take the T out of camp
and remember that doing the racing
environmentally is almost always the
correct economic approach in the long
run think about that one so there and
it's supposed to be snowing by now Danny
I figured does everybody be heading for
the door so I made it really short
you